Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this will be
my full black panther wakanda forever post credit
scene my explaining the ending of the movie
if you're brand new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos because there
is a whole bunch of stuff that they set up in
this movie for future movies that we have to talk
about I'm working on a full breakdown easter eggs
for the entire movie that'll post tomorrow as
well careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
the end of the movie yet but I'll start with name
Wars ending scene because it's probably one of the
most important scenes from the end of the movie
before the actual post-credits scene they use
special subtitles to distinguish when characters
were speaking different languages like there was
namor's original Mayan language like this ancient
language back from the 15 1600s those were the
blue subtitles the yellow subtitles were when they
were speaking native wakandan and then they just
spoke English without subtitles so anytime Namor
is talking to his other people like namora in this
ending scene they're speaking in their home tongue
using the blue subtitles namor is all pissed off
about the way that their final battle with the
wakandans and Black Panther went down in ask
namor why he knelt to the Black Panther they're
in wakanda why would you do something like that
he claims that black panther is the most powerful
person on the planet in the most powerful Nation
on the surface world and they formed a strong
bond with their shared tragic histories the
loss of their families they found common cause
in that final battle that's why she didn't kill
him and now that they're much more closely bonded
like they actually feel like they could be friends
eventually if Namor awaits the surface world
will come for wakanda and their vibranium kind
of like they teased earlier in the movie the rest
of the world wants everything that wakanda has and
when they do that shuri black panther will turn
to them turn to nameor for help and that will
finally fulfill his idea of an alliance between
their two powerful Empires and together they'll
burn the rest of the world which he was talking to
shuri about earlier you said earlier and I heard
you on the beach you wanted to burn the rest of
the world so Namor is still planning long term
his attack against the surface world that has not
ended he's just waiting for wakanda's time of need
which I believe that they're going to pay off or
it'll culminate in Captain America 4 or New World
Order or in the Thunderbolts movie because that
was what the whole Val plot was setting up the
idea that she wants wakandan vibranium she
wants all vibranium to be controlled by the
United States she even told Everett Ross and the
others inside the building that she dreams of that
meaning she will eventually one day invade wakanda
probably with the help of the Thunderbolts I just
did a video about this a couple weeks ago like
that's the whole idea why she's assembling this
team people who are powerful enough to fight this
new black panther are the forces of wakanda I'll
talk more about that in a separate video because
there's like a billion other things that the movie
set up that don't have anything to do with the
actual post-credits scene that's more about the
future of the Black Panther character in the Black
Panther sequels the post-credit scene is more of
a mid-credits scene usually Marvel movies have
two post-credits scenes this time they only had
one for a very specific reason and it was more
of a mid-credits scene after a brief time Jump
at the end of the movie they show that shuri has
traveled to Nokia's home in Haiti to spend time
with her and perform her ritual wakanda grieving
ceremony like she meant to do at the beginning of
the movie burning her wakandan funeral garments
from t'challa's burial and it was their way of
saying goodbye to the ones that they've lost like
moving on with their lives they have a really cool
montage and flashbacks to actually pictures of
t'challa like that's how t'challa was in the
movie himself Chadwick Boseman they just included
footage from previous movies when characters were
remembering him particularly shuri's character
when she completes the ceremony she finds that
Naki has brought t'challa's son to meet her his
Haitian name is toussaint but his true wakanda
name he says is Prince t'challa son of King
t'challa he says he was named after his father
just to make everything clear like sure he knows
immediately who he is like wait a minute this is
your son that means that he's such a son so you
see the wheels turning in her head but there
were probably a couple people in the audience
that just didn't get it so they had the child
actually say it I am the son of King t'challa
my name is t'challa Naki explains that older
t'challa had told her about his illness that was
slowly killing him before the snap so she had made
plans to help raise the boy outside of wakanda
away from the throne no matter what that was
before the events of Avengers Infinity War like
she got pregnant before infinity war that means
even if he had lived like even if he came back
after the snap and nothing bad had happened they
would have still raised the boy away from wakanda
in the throne so that he wouldn't have been
overburdened as a child with all the expectations
of someday becoming King and becoming the next
Black Panther and living up to his father's Legacy
t'challa wanted him to have a normal childhood and
this actually flows with the comic book version
of black panther Ryan coogler talked about this
very particular storyline and I think that they're
adapting it for t'challa's son young t'challa I'll
explain that in a second there was a really cool
clip of Ryan cooler talking about this like oh
they're just gonna do that for his son Naki also
explains that shuri and t'challa's mother ramonda
met him before she passed away she knew all about
him and kept the secret herself because earlier
in the movie she says her entire family is gone
but notice that she doesn't say that her entire
family is dead she just says God and this is just
part of them keeping the boy secret because young
t'challa asks shuri Auntie shuri he calls her if
she's good at keeping secrets meaning they won't
tell anyone in wakanda or anyone else around the
world for that matter like The Avengers any other
potential allies of theirs about him for years
Nakia says that he was born after the snap so
she was already prepared for t'challa to die and
when he was snapped she left before her pregnancy
became obvious or before she was discovered by
the other wakandans she gave birth to him shortly
after after the five-year time Jump had started
so charting the timeline of the snap this movie
is meant to take place about three years after
Avengers endgame around the same time as Thor
love and thunder and Ant-Man 3 Quantumania there's
actually a very special easter egg for Ant-Man
Quantumania earlier in the movie that I'll talk
about during my full breakdown in easter eggs for
the entire movie you may have spotted it's like a
blink and you'll miss it Chiron kind of easter egg
on the news they did the same thing with Thor
love and thunder inside Spider-Man no way home
there was a Thor easter egg inside Spider-Man
no way home but this timeline means that young
t'challa is about seven maybe like a little over
seven years old not quite eight years old and now
Marvel's plan is that m'baku will take the Throne
of wakanda like they're separating the roles of
Black Panther and the ruler of wakanda because he
shows up for the ceremony saying that shuri will
not join us today and everything's good between
them like they don't have any beef between the two
of them sure he does not want to take the throne
it wants young t'challa is old enough to come into
his power they'll likely do that in a future movie
where he'll wind up fighting m'baku challenging
him for the throne and become the next king of
wakanda like his father now if you think about
the timeline of the movies and all the phases we
have Secret Wars coming up at the end of Marvel
phase six I think it's going to be closer to like
black panther 4 before they try to do something
like that just because of how long it takes for
black panther sequels to come out I don't think
they're going to wait that long for black panther
3 to come out in we'll have m'baku sitting on the
throne doing the day-to-day business of ruling
wakanda, shuri will just continue being the
current black panther until young t'challa is also
old enough to take that mantle as well but I think
it's the same idea like if he's old enough to to
beat m'baku in a challenge like physically strong
enough then by that time he'll also probably be
ready to take the mantle of Black Panther from
shuri they also did this thing in the movie where
a bunch of characters either get fired from their
jobs or they just quit their jobs and go off and
do different things which explains why they can
have crossovers with other movies while wakanda is
busy doing wakanda things like m'baku is going to
be watching the fort while all these other major
characters like shuri's black panther okoye's
character go off and do other things in other
movies what I'm expecting though is that we'll
see young t'challa like this young actor here
in a Young Avengers project before he becomes
the next Black Panther probably other movies
too I mean it's gonna be a while because he's
so young right now we might see him a little bit
during black panther 3 like another reminder oh
yeah by the way he's a little bit older but he's
still not quite ready to become the next Black
Panther or the next king of wakanda but we'll
see more of him and they'll develop his character
and then eventually by the time he is ready to
fight m'baku, challenge him for the throne and
take the mantle black panther we'll have already
seen him in a couple movies and it'll be sort of
like a spy Spider-Man Arc inside the MCU where you
see him mentored for a while and then eventually
come into his own as opposed to the original
black panther who showed up already being black
panther we posted all The Lion King memes when the
first black panther came out like for t'challa's
character they were going with a lot of themes
from The Lion King now it's basically the same
idea with his son like the first Black Panther
movie was more like the beginning of the Lion
King the Black Panther wakanda forever post credit
scene is more like the end of The Lion King movie
and talking about the long-term plans of Marvel
inside the MCU like which character is going to
be really huge down the road I think they're
positioning young t'challa as this next Black
Panther to be sort of like the Crown Jewel of the
MCU kind of like Spider-Man is right now really
popular character that everybody loves around the
world in a lot of the MCU story turns around them
just gonna take a little while for him to age
up into that just gonna be a hot minute before
he gets there this is the clip of Ryan coogler
where he kind of foreshadows what the story of
young t'challa is going to be he lost his father
very young and basically he was like a boy King
you know and it went away for a little while can't
you know comes back and then inherits the throne
as a Young Man and by the time he's to Charlie's
age in the MCU he's been a king for a long time
you know and and been without a father for a long
time you know and so that that character was much
much different and you know so I was trying to
figure out how to how to incorporate these these
you know these books uh into into this story that
that that that I was inhering and trying to flesh
out so In that clip he was talking about adapting
the original Black Panther movie because in the
comics the original version of t'challa grew up
away from wakanda like he grew up in America when
he came back to wakanda to become king and be the
full-on Black Panther his father had already died
so a lot of his story was him figuring that
out without having the benefit of his father
there to teach him about it and now in the MCU
that's going to be the story for young t'challa
probably he'll have to figure out what it means
to be black panther what it means to be the king
of wakanda without the benefit of his father
there and if they were ever to bring a version
of Chadwick Boseman back inside the ancestral
plane to speak to someone it would probably
be too young t'challa when he eventually takes
the throne and takes the mantle Black Panther
maybe maybe they'll do like a CG force ghost
version of Chadwick Boseman then but only
then if you have any other questions about what
happened in the post-credits scene or at the end
of the movie just write them in the comments below
my full breakdown in easter eggs video will post
tomorrow where I'll talk about everything that
happened during the movie everyone click here
for that video I'll update the link as soon as I
post it and click here for my brand new Deadpool
3 video thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!